Beat up, this is gotta be taking up
a tremendous amount of your time.
Like what if, are you doing anything
else in addition to doing this?
Are you setting aside everything else
in your life other than your family
obligations? I have
two jobs, man. One, uh,
help accelerate society to try and deal
with this historic transition, Maryanne,
and to stay married. Those only
things I'm about. Wow, that's a,
that's a powerful path. Um, now when,
when you're looking at the opposition
and you look in all the other people that
are running for president
and wonder whether or not
they're going to be there by
the time the elections roll around,
would it, what are you saying that's,
it's really interesting, Joe. Holy Cow.
That one of the funnest things about
running for president is you run into all
the other candidates on the trail in Iowa,
in New Hampshire.
So I'm like just hanging out
backstage with like the gang.
It's so interesting and fun.
It is weird sometimes,
but I really liked most of them. And
so sometimes people ask me like, Hey,
who do you want your running mate to be?
And I'm just like,
it really depends upon who I just click
with best because we're just going to be
on the trail all the time together.
So having met a bunch of them,
I got to say most of the candidates are
really genuine patriots who just want to
try and do something positively.
See the country's heading
in the wrong direction.
I could work with most all of them,
uh,
in terms of who I think is going
to be there in the end. Man,
it's really interesting. Uh,
I mean, one reason I like,
I will say that apparently the mainstream
press had it out for Bernie last time
where they were just going to,
like,
I have a friend who worked in the media
and they were like, just like, you know,
kneecap Bernie. Why was he
going the kneecap brain? Um,
well it's like there's definitely
something going on where like certain
corporate media companies
have certain candidates,
they kind of want to tip the scales for
a little brown and people that they want
to like tip it against.
Well,
they thought that Bernie was going
to get in the way of Hillary winning.
Is that the idea? Yeah.
Yeah. I mean they, they,
they were in the Hillary camp for sure.
Yeah. And so that wasn't just the media,
that was also the DNC,
which is now on the record.
So now happily,
certainly the DNC has turned a totally
different leaf where the DNC is like,
we're not going to do anything that like,
and your peers with Eddie Woods prospects.
Well, what they did was a disaster.
A disaster in terms of
public image too. Yeah. Yeah.
It was both substantively and like
perception wise, the disaster for them.
So this time I got to say, and that the
team is turned over almost entirely,
like it's almost totally different
people. And then the media, I,
we have the sense that, you know, they're,
they're still feeling out who they're
going to try and put the thumb on the
scale for. Uh, so Ernie, Bernie
is still running though, right?
It looks like he's running it. You want
to know something that's really stupid,
but it changed my opinion of him.
He was being grilled by some of them
at the airport with a camera and he was
pretending to talk on the phone,
but you could tell he wasn't really on
the phone white and I saw that and I was
like, oh, you can't do that. You
can't do that. You could say,
I'm not giving impromptu interviews.
Thank you very much. And keep walking.
Like if you want to interview me,
do it through the correct channels.
But he didn't do that.
He pretended to be on the phone.
It's a weird thing because if you're
willing to do that, like that's just,
this is deceptive. Especially if
you can actually see the deception,
which clearly you can see the video
of the fucking phone is not on.
It's like he's,
it's like you could see his text messages
and he's like, and the guy saying
to him, you're not on the phone.
I can tell you're not on the phone.
And he keeps walking. It's like,
I know that's a stupid thing,
but it's like, Huh. We all,
we all saw out details about different
people in different areas, you know,
and like, you know,
it's like, I think, uh,
one reason I'm so grateful for this
opportunity as I was like, you know,
like you actually can get a sense of
different people in different environments
and it does end up impacting
your, your perception. So I mean,
people made decisions on much
lesser data points in that,
that way. I'll remember what the fuck's
his name from Vermont who uh, Howard Dean.
The Dean scream man, the freaking
[inaudible] he's from where he was from.
Vermont. Vermont. Yeah. That
scream killed him. Sank him.
Do you remember the Chappelle show parody?
The Chappelle show party of
that was hysterical. It's funny,
but the fact that that it was
just because it was a loud, like,
as a person who works in
front of audiences a lot,
when you're yelling into a
microphone, like the, the,
you hear like, especially if you
don't have monitors in front of you,
what you hear is like everything.
You hear the crowd screaming,
you hear everything. And if you're
yelling into that microphone,
you're not realizing what it sounds
like as a recording with him is like,
yeah. And that was it. One scream,
I imagine,
imagine that one scream literally
changed the course of that man's life.
One and most of that might've changed
the course of the nation's history.
Might've crazy.
I don't know if that would happen today.
I think especially post Trump,
one thing that has happened is we're
willing to forgive so much more,
you know, in some ways. Yeah.
In some ways. No, man. I
mean, I feel like, you know,
like some, some people, uh, uh,
more forgiving than others for different
things and for sure there's certainly,
yeah, it varies. But it would be
interesting to imagine what a,
what the dean scream
would result in today.
Hopefully I'm not the person that tests
it out. Scream, please don't scream.